hello everyone carry mornin with film
courage the radio show we're here
outside the studio with Roth Greco and
Seth Kaplan they join us on our
roundtable discussion as well as Gregory
main and we had a college student email
us the other day and asked what the best
place is to find out about independent
film so we're wondering is there a
dedicated platform for discovery of
independent film that you know of and if
not how can we change that I mean
there's a lot of this lot of great
resources on the net I mean for news i
don't really go to a indieWIRE but i
think long term that there might end up
being some kind of platform that that
every film is uploaded to developing
netflix but if it gets to the point
where it's easy to find I'm not sure it
doesn't cease to become an independent
film I think by definition independent
films are films are constantly being
discovered their new and fresh voices so
I think it's almost that's part of the
alert for a lot of people is that they
are kind of cool to find it's like
little gem hunting and the cost in
finding the new most interesting
material there's never an easy resource
you gotta go out there and hunt it down
yeah man I think in new wires are going
filmmaker magazine has a lot of good
articles and their blog and that kind of
thing I think a lot of following the Ted
hopes truly free film there's a lot of
disinformation I want to make things
like Netflix where there's a lot of
indie movies that are streamed a lot of
old classic movies like criterion movies
and things like that that better you can
just get streamed on so that you might
find a director that you like or go
order the thing that has like an
alternative or independent film and you
might see one movie lighten that follow
that directors work or something like
that on and yeah I don't I don't know
what a platform would be eventually for
it i think it's all going to become kind
of modernized as theirs
the different types of films and then
Ralph after the the show when we took
our headphones off you brought up an
interesting kind of debate that I know a
lot of people have talked about as far
as you know you come out here you do end
up working in the industry but it's not
maybe the creative part or it's just not
exactly in the area that you want to be
working in but yes you are in the
industry and then you kind of get
pigeonholed and you kind of stay there
and maybe you're making great money and
then the trappings of success kind of
come along can you touch on that for us
how there's kind of this way that you
almost get sucked in um yeah no I think
I think it goes to kind of what with the
whole theme of the show kind of became
which was kind of you know what what is
defining what kind of crew you want and
then sticking to it or or adapting with
it and I think a lot of you know though
the industry is huge I mean it's going
to LA and becoming part of the film
industry doesn't necessarily mean that
you're going to go be a director some
people can you know go be a grip or
working as a set decorator on indie
movies on big movies on it's not that
hard to got to get a production
assistant job and work your way up if
that's what you want to do and that's we
were committed to along the way though
you and I guess it's true with that with
anything in life it's like you know if
you go to graduate school for 10 years I
mean you're going to be a professional
student but with this the business does
tend to define you by what you do so say
if you do come out here one of you
director you into becoming you know a
camera grip or something like that and
you work on a bunch of films um you can
people will know you as that you're
going to have to make you know be brave
and say look I'm going to stop doing
that I'm going to shift my gears um the
the other side of is that by doing that
you gained tremendous experience you
have access beyond belief of
professionals and people and things but
um you know it i think everybody comes
to let where it basically what do i want
to be doing and and some people may be
fine just having i know a lot of people
who are fine they came out here you know
ten years ago want to be directors and
stuff and then became coordinators or
producers or you know television
producers and they're fine with it it's
just that's what they want to be doing
there's nothing wrong with that it's a
successful career it is a business of
relationships it's not so much a
business
I'm going to send my resume and get
hired as a business of building
relationships and interacting with
people having personal relationships
with people and gaining their kind of
trust so that they'll hire you on other
jobs and and do that and that's what's
different then say you know any other
business where you can go you know be
part of a company and you know move up
the ladder despite you know getting
raises so so I think it's a choice
people have to make enough to be aware
of early on I mean for me I completely
agree they get his relationship based
and those and that and that i have found
for myself and starting out in in the
industry and when I when I look at
people who are just entering industry
having a clear definition of what they
want to do makes it so much easier to
help them if someone says I want to be
an actor writer but I'm kind of
interested editing also you're a little
you don't have as much direction say you
know how can I help this person right
it's very clear out I want to be a
publicist okay I can I know some
publicist I can call I can you know
person seems your like focus in my
experience um what I'd start making
movies when I was in high school in
college when you do look like like you
know we need you out here on the student
you do everything I heard the director
sounds the actor you're the photographer
your episode sir crime service and what
I noticed is like a lesson for me is
people say oh are you a detail-oriented
person like a detail-oriented and I
noticed the details of directing never
captured me like I lines really didn't
care even wardrobe choices of colors it
never capture me with the other details
of corruption in terms of like the theme
of the movie and how it would correspond
to an audience right down to what time
lunch is coming and how many shots were
going to get those details couldn't
escape my head so I basically tried and
tried working on films of all kinds
different capacities and as a details
that captured me that kind of drove me
into the producing role and that's a
role that I love to do and that really
helped me when I by the time I come out
here I knew that's what I wanted to do
and so it was really beneficial when I
meet people won't be in a position to
help me to say I'm dedicated to
producing that it's what i want to do
but then they were able to kind of help
me with their assets in the producing
field